للعام الرابع على التوالي تقدم جائزه
بصيره للمكفوفين في السعوديه هذه جائزه
تاتي على هامش مؤتمر طب العيون الدولي
المقام هنا كل عام لكن هذه جائزه تكرم
اصحاب الانجازات من المكفوفين
دكتوره شادي النعلاوات من الاردن انت كمان
اليوم من المكرمين بجائزه بصيره وكنتي
حريسه انه تطلعي تقولي قصه على المسرح
عملت مفاجاه
عمر 18 سنه وبعدين
انضميتي
لفئه احكي لنا عن جائزه قصيره الانجاز
الاكبر الي بتشعر انك عملت
توام مع اخت مبصره
لما صارت مشكله البصريه يكون دائما اسال
رب العالمين احكي له يا رب انت صبرني انا
اصغر من اني افهم حكمتك بس اكيد في حكمه
انه اختارني انا ما اختارها هي يعني من
خلال هذا الشيء ومن خلال الصعوبات اللي
واجهت اهلي فيهم ما كانوا ملايين جهاد
داعمه فداك الوقت انها تدربهم وتعلمهم
قررت ان يكون هذا مسيرتي هذا بدعم من اهلي
طبعا انه لازم نبحث على الاسر اللي مش
ملاقيه حدا يعرفها شو بتساوي لما يصير
عندها طفل كفيف
استاذ عبد الله الهمامي من الامارات
اللي رافقتني في 29 سنه وهي معي منذ
الولاده هي اللي تعلمت هي اللي ربت اللي
علمت هي اللي وصلتني للي انا وصلت لها
فكيف انا اتقاسم انا يعني اقل شيء اني
اعمل يعني اضع راسي تحت قدمها اللي همم
يعني هي اللي وصلتني
اللي انا فيه بعدين الله سبحانه وتعالى
[موسيقى]
الاستاذه شريفه المالكي من البحرين انت
ضمن الرواد المقرر المكرمين اليوم ايوه كل
من عن انجازاتك لان هذه انجازات مهمه على
مستوى الوطن العربي الحمد لله الله كرمني
ان اقدم انجازات البلادي وللفئه المكفوفين
بشكل خاص اييه من ضمن الانجازات تدريب
الحاسوب للمكفوفين بالتعاون مع المجلس
الاعلى للمراه مثل ما ذكر
حاليا همم اعمل على ااا او في افتتاح مطعم
للمكفوفين وهو دارك
بالتعاون مع جمعيه الاقتصاد للهام والفندق
وايضا
معسكر خاص للمراه الكفيفه
[موسيقى]